Hello everyone
my name is Guillaume Erard
I'm the Media Manager and Archiving Director for the IAF
I'm in Tokyo Station
and I'm going to meet Irie Yoshinobu Shihan
We're going to board the Joetsu line of the Shinkansen
which should take us in a little less than an hour to the city of Takasaki.
Takasaki is the city that will be hosting the next IAF Congress.
in September 2016.
They're currently building a brand new sports facility
and we'll be the first ones to use it
which is pretty exciting.
Now, that being said,
I'm pretty sure that many of you had never heard of Takasaki before
and basically, what Irie Sensei and I are going to do today,
is that we're going to find out what the city is about,
see how the construction work is going,
and also, try to find out what sort of activities
that attendees can take part in between classes.
I hope that you like what you see,
and we'll be looking forward to see you in Takasaki.